the next presenter is Jack Valenti who
is the president of the Motion Picture
Association of America now I know Jack
very well and he's a good friend but not
the world's most thrilling speaker but
let me put it this way
I suggest while you're listening to him
you do not drive or operate heavy
machinery
welcome mr. Jack Valenti
a night like this is another chance to
say that the making of a film is a group
effort from the moment of its conception
to its unveiling in a theater by way of
proof there are 1,200 distributors and
exhibitors for more than 90 nations
around the globe who are tonight
concluding the first American film
market meeting in Los Angeles we welcome
this new addition to the International
family of film and they like viewers
everywhere or watching these awards
tonight we're giving them to a few
people but they're the result of the
work of thousands in the production of
every film there is a group of
technicians whose sole job it is to
bring to realization the writers fancy
the director's vision and the producers
dream hundreds of skilled technicians
and artists contributed thousands of
painstaking hours to bring the magic of
The Empire Strikes Back to the screen
this year the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences has chosen to honor a
special-effects staff George Lucas's The
Empire Strikes Back for their
outstanding work
because of the size of the concept and
the quality of the execution the Academy
Board of Governors has beamed this film
to be representative highest quality of
motion picture special effects the
Academy is proud to honor Richard Edlund
Brian Johnson Dennis Muren and Bruce
Nicholson all of whom under the guidance
of George Lucas have created a milestone
science fiction fantasy gentlemen it's a
great honor for me to present you for
these special
thank you
first I must thank George Lucas and Gary
Kurtz who gave us the opportunity to
work on these great films also my
colleagues Jim Blu Joe Johnston Ralph
McQuarrie and Harrison Ellen Shaw of
course my family and the crew thank you
very much
I'd like to sang the english effects
crew and ILM and I'd like to thank Gary
Kurtz George Lucas Irvin Kershner my two
daughters Claire and Lucy Kate my wife
Jenny thanks very much I'd like to thank
my mom and John Berg and Phil Tippett
and Ken and all the camera department
I'd like to thank a great special
effects crew and in particular the
optical department who I worked so
closely with to my wife family and
friends for their support throughout the
project and to the force for allowing me
to be here tonight to receive this alone
I should mention that price waterhouse
also guards a secret of what Jack
Valenti does for a living
the next award is for outstanding
achievement in sound and to present the
nominees here are miss Bernadette Peters
and mr. Billy Dee Williams